[Music]
this is not how you'd want your pilot to
behave but crazy as this flying looks we
all benefit from it this is the new
Boeing 737 max being put through some
vomit-inducing tests to make sure is
safe for us
the 737 may be the best-selling
commercial jet better going on 50 years
old it's getting long in the tooth hence
the reboot the 737 max is Boeing's
attempt to get a few more decades of
life out of it and a few thousand more
sales check out the number above the
front wheel one a zero zero one the very
first 737 max to come off the line and
it's here at Boeing Field in Seattle for
testing the max is actually the
fourth-generation 737 due to enter
service next year it's got new engines
split tip winglets airframe updates and
some new tech in the cockpit all of
which should make it at least 14% more
efficient and 40 percent quieter that's
the reason for those new Chevron's at
the back of the jet engine by the way
but a reengineered plane means a full
battery of extreme test flights before
it can enter regular service this is
really giving you that kind of Tesla
look isn't it looking yeah giant
flat-screen all the way across all the
way for a cockpit I mean if you've come
in here and look at it this is the same
as our brand new airplane it's a 787 so
your responsibility is flying these
planes on test flights on flights that
are really about gathering data the idea
that when we go out and test fly
airplane is to bring it to a safe level
for the flying public waste we fly at
the edge of the envelope all the time
even sometimes we fly outside the flight
envelope of the airplane let's have a
quick tour of this aircraft and see
exactly what they do
your over-wing exits are located here
and here they're actually open at the
moment if we walk down through this is
the pit this is where the engineers sit
this is where the action really happens
they'll be monitoring almost anything
you can think of on this plane from
these seats and from the thousands of
sensors that are dotted all the way
around everything from fuel flow to
aerodynamics to handling we keep going
down you can actually they have oxygen
supplies up here so that they can do
experiments with the cabin unpressurized
if they need to these are actually tanks
of nitrogen these are used to purge the
instruments if they get wet to make sure
the readings are exactly accurate keep
going down this looks like some sort of
a high-tech I don't know sci-fi like
engine but it's not this is clear
plastic tubing
hundred and fifty feet of it that can be
let out the back of the plane and trail
behind they can use that to take
measurements of what the air is doing
way beyond any turbulence caused by the
plane itself as you can see not much in
the way of a galley or kitchen at the
back but there are in flight
refreshments they're kept in this cooler
here fancy new planes like Boeing's
carbon-fiber 787 Dreamliner or air buses
gargantuan a380 may get most of the
attention but the 737 is the plane that
you're most likely to fly on they make
up one third of the total worldwide
fleet so getting this one right matters
[Music]